good morning John today I discovered
that people don't look at you funny if
you're in an airport vlogging and you're
talking on the phone at the same time so
I'm gonna pretend like we're talking on
the phone this isn't actually my video
for today I'm actually making a pre-made
video because I want to talk about a new
thing that we are going to be doing see
YouTube has decided to let us in to the
little live-streaming party and so we
are going to join them and I start doing
live streams and we're gonna start that
today today is the official launch of
youtube.com slash live which is where
you will be able to find YouTube live
streams and John and I are gonna be
doing that and I'm very excited John is
doing a show today from 2:30 to 4:30
Eastern Time
I think that you should come and
whoever's on the phone other in the
phone I think they should come to in
these alive streams John and I are gonna
be talking about you know nerdy things
just going to read 19th century poetry
and I'm gonna talk about theoretical
physics and we're gonna browse reddit
together and we're gonna read books and
play songs and it's gotta be fun so
check out John's livestream 2:30 to 4:30
at youtube.com slash vlogbrothers which
is our YouTube channel and we will be
doing more of them in the future I hope
that you enjoy them John you will see me
later today